[Music]  just when we thought the dust had  settled in the Battle of Kim Kardashian  versus Taylor Swift check the weather  forecast says possible shade four days  it started on Instagram on Monday Kim  posted this throwback photo at her  husband Kanye West's famous exhibit  which featured naked wax figures of  celebrities including Taylor it's the  song that initially sparked the Kimye  Swift few I feel like me and Taylor my  still has sex Wow I made that famous  then on Tuesday Swift posts a photo from  her British Vogue spread the caption a  lyric from her song I did something bad  I knew that just a narcissist but they  love me both posts sent fans into a  frenzy Kim fans posting snake emojis  Taylor fans posting rat emojis it's  exhausting was this a case of  interesting timing or did Kim and Taylor  really shade each other  send me a rat or a snake emoji on  Twitter letting me know whose side  you're on I'm at Deidre Behar  [Music]